on va passer maintenant au gros dos du
jour c'est l'interview qu'a donnée cyril
hanouna
ce matin je crois que c'était
d'enseignants le parisien parisien en
nous informant de toutes les nouveautés
de la rentrée seuls malades et nous
allons la vôtre des nouveaux profs je
suis pas des faux que j'appelle des
dizaines d'appels cyril donc fort je lui
parle parce que j'ai un mot qui les
concernent non alors dans les nouveautés
bien il ya un fameux théo théo le
terreau bas qui va faire son arrivée en
rémission
rappelez vous il était venu sur le sur
le plateau et il avait dit tout le bien
qu'il pensait de notre ami matthieu
delormeau regarde et où c'est notre
stagiaire
quel est le chroniqueur le moins sympa
moment sympa ben c'est simple en un an
et demi que je suis où je travaille pour
touche pas à mon poste mais il ne m'a
jamais dit bonjour c'est matthieu
delormeau
je vous promets que je ne les pas bons
je peux vous le dire il ya juste une
fois on a pu discuter tous les deux
s'étaient ils devaient faire une
chronique l'année dernière devait danser
sur des jingles genève en salle de
montage
il m'a regardé de haut en bas il m'a dit
je désolé ça fait 20 ans que je fais de
la télé c'est pas un gosse de 14 ans qui
va m'apprendre mon métier on vous
rappelle ça alors d'abord c'était une
vanne au second 2 le bon degré c'est là
que je n'ai pas dit bonjour parce que je
sentais qu'il était seul ou sur des
contrats je m'ai fait je me méfie de la
personne l'alerté aux jours de grands
pros et tout jeune mais à mon avis il a
beaucoup beaucoup de talent vous y
croyez évidemment je montais au filet il
est malin il est totalement dans dans
son époque pour le fréquenter discuter
très très souvent avec lui il est super
drôle et je pense qu il va cartonner à
la rentrée va cartonner c'est sûr et
surtout il espiègle il est jeune la
peine 21 ans qui parle de candidats
qu'on dit non non pas du coup bah oui ou
non mais lestée gurry c'est là les deux
camps des très très bien le super man
tient le tabac souffre c'est un peu gros
c'est ma partir de man il ya un sens de
rigolade lettres chagrin ce balai brosse
yeux on n'aurait pas dire terme aux
exactions sur un bon crochet désole
vraiment terrassera c'est vrai allons
messieurs vous sur tille père dark heart
non mais t'es pas et il est excellent et
après un des rares où il est drôle et
les brillants dans six mois il a pris la
place de maxime
[Applaudissements]
il a confirmé il a confirmé la présence
de votre protégé
nabila wipo par semaine normalement sur
la la ça c'est bien la rentrée placée
content d'être en septembre un petit
cocktail c'est vrai c'est fantastique
franchement je l'attendais depuis
longtemps je suis super content elle est
brillante elle est intelligente elle
représente son époque je suis enchanté
là justement elle est bien foutu si elle
est brillante et l'état mais à côté de
ça des réflexions deux ans plus tard
foutu ça va pas booster et tenez vous un
peu mon t elle enfin m6 ma dernière
ben écoute mais c'est moi c'est pas la
vienne deux dernières de se dire mon
émission oui alors lui revient pas
l'année prochaine at war non je crois
pas qu'en si elle est brillante et
intelligente
alors d'accord contient monaco mais
justement qu'elle ne joue pas la cote en
plateau les deux meilleures émissions
que nabila est fait à mon sens c'est les
deux premières qu'elle avait fait n'en
touche pas à mon poste où elle était
ultra candide après elle a joué de son
personnage
si c'est pour dire des trucs comme l'a
dit l'autre jour on t'a dit mais les
poisons faisait pas des animaux non à 10
ans je fais mais moi je sais très bien
nabila allez sûrement pas aussi idiote
tel de telles leçons de mer les masters
je voudrais ce qui reste naturel ton dit
comme elle elle allait très bien comme
ça quoi c'est ce qu'on dit on dit elle
est bête de loin mais loin devant des
deux bêtes
oui regardez de ce mobile à quoi ça
ressemble c'est ça démoulez avec votre
talon attention le premier qui déboule
attention vous attendez mon top 1 2 3
démouler
bien déroulé à laurent fabius il est
ministre de quoi et du poisson du
poisson avec laurent fin du snuipp et
choqué très honnêtement oui moi tout ce
qui touche aux animaux je suis gentil je
défend énormément la fondation bardot
[Rires]
autres autre recrue dans l'émission
c'est adrien lemaître ah oui j'allais
lancer dans secret story oui et oui avec
le doigt tous sachent le bon et c'est
vrai qu'il a beaucoup de talent et le
style adria c'est ça bonsoir mon benji
c'est bien bah ça va ça va très bien
c'est l'heure des bonus de mister
secret' que personne ne bouge c'est une
tradition chaque année un candidat
laisse une séquence dans l'histoire de
citrate story alors vivions va revenir
sur un événement marquant de cette
saison la révélation évidemment d'autres
secrets avec nathalie et bien nathalie
vivian je vous propose de revenir en
images sur la réaction des habitants
quand ils ont découvert votre secret on
s'est bien marré
[Applaudissements]
et il y aura également une nouvelle
séquence et ça je pense que ça va être
très très dur parce que c'est ce qu'on
vit au quotidien c'est les love story
ex-rn veut qu'on découvre les fictions
des coulisses de l'émission c'est vrai
que l'émission elle commence nous il ya
eu la partie que vous voyez chez vous
mais l'émission avec le bronze pour mis
en avant elle commence à la dent dans
les coulisses c'est une bonne idée mais
je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de censure à
magali we love story non non sur mon
plombier sur le casting je trouve très
frais et je trouve ça bien parce que ça
rajeunit un peu tout ou le plateau et
trouve ça vraiment bien et ensuite je
trouve que sur love story ça va être
très très drôles j'adore
moi j'ai hâte d'y être tu serais bien ce
qui serait bien pour love story c'est
qu'ils aient passé marqué une fiction
qui serait bien c'est qu'il ya des
vraies images
ouais non mais tu sais très bien que
jean siry tout va mais que les vraies
images du vaccin le maquillage mais bien
évidemment
linea temps alors il ya d'autres
nouveautés ya d'autres nouveautés alors
là il ya eu ce qui me concerne que j'ai
découvert là les ans et tous les
vendredis ça j'avais je devais te
vendredi midi bazin et castanet de
présenter touche pas à mon people vous
avez découvert tant les wizzards oui
alors si j'ai dit on va essayer ce qui
si elle s'invente en est et qui peut me
répondre c'est que ferait définition
parce que j'avais découvert en même
temps que je les légers ados mal ou la
surprise à l'eau il est la voici la
voilà j'y crois et labo bailleval a
exigé partir en vacances
quel tahar bala mais de leur moi aussi
j'ai vu il a proposé de alors un truc
people aussi alors annuel non il y aura
deux ou trois prime
je pense que le prague de mathieu ça va
être l'événement de l'année
très drôle j'attends ça avec impatience
mais vraiment et bravo cyril s'est enfin
c'est pas parce que ce sont les
dernières émissions que vous devez dire
des conneries et alors la bonne nouvelle
ça plus le jeudi soir apparemment chaque
jeudi soir il y aura un prenne sa façon
récurrente apparemment cette année veut
vraiment imposer des rendez-vous des
marques
bon évidemment ça vous et croyez peut
pas mener le rail vos contrats notamment
mais pas que et je crois que vous allez
cartonné aussi dans la proposition vous
a été faite concernant une émission sur
le mariage ou la wii ne sait alors c'est
vrai que tu as écrit derrière son
travail et son ex berjalliens castaldi
sera au tour d'un mariage mariage ce
sera c'est le mariage le divorce
s'efface que dans le mariage sera le
mariage sera au tour ce sera au tour ne
sera pas une émission comme on l'a vu
comment beaucoup d'accords voilà vous
avez compris alors céline est également
revenu sur son ami yann barthès à
l'artiste qui l'a pas ratée alors
barthez vrai qu'il avait dit qu'en fait
c'était la seule personne qui pouvait
pas les écrins pour reprendre couette
mais bon ça c'est ccc du langage
ces images et on va dire bart et ce
n'est pas mon ami et ne le sera jamais
on vient pas du même milieu
c'est lui qui avait ouvert les
hostilités en se moquant 2 x 2 3 fois de
mon public qu'il traitait
bof sans cerveau est vrai et pour moi
c'était intolérable mais là ça ça a fait
ma matinée à l'express j'ai lu
l'interview à voix haute toute la
réponse je lui montrerai rien d'autre à
[ __ ] avec y'a que cyril hanouna pour
répondre un truc comme ça en interview
parce qu'il dit pas que ça il dit qu'il
appelait à 23h30
oui j'en ai voilà un nom mais le lien
c'est l'honnêteté du gaillacois
le gac et ils traquent h et l'autre qui
à mon avis devait tomber dans son pyjama
en désordre là lâche séries tu lui
propose de prendre un café le non non
non je veux dire merci
face à lui moi je dis que c'est
l'habitude jeffrey texte plus vite que
son ombre
oui mais là il appeler carrément sait
même pas partie des briques ont
également sur une déclaration de cyril
sur le choix de camille combal à tf1 en
gros il dit voilà cette bonne sens mais
il pense que sa place aurait été plus
sur m6 la semaine
bien sûr il à camille combal il a raison
sur tout juste qu'on a analysées à
propos de cette émission un casting pour
y penser j'ai peur que pour camille ce
soit un piège je pense que peut-être en
décryptant cyril il se dit que c'était
peut-être pas la place de camille combal
j'ai peur que ce soit perdant perdant
pour camille mois danse avec les stars
alors on fait pas rejouer à ce que dit
c'est pas encore tout ce qui va faire
non sur sa ses vallées son analyse est
une analyse comme son interview
politique j'ai trouvé que c'était assez
fort n'a l'impression que presqu'île et
patrons de chaînes ou en tout cas qu'il
a une vision globale de la télé c'est
pour ça que c'est un décryptage c'est
intéressant mais bernard montiel alias
nana aller la nartuby ce trail à dire
moi je jouais marinade il a exactement
un euro mettez moi le texte vous
[Rires]
à thé vert s'il vous plaît du personnel
mais les redescendre silence et attend
et c'est très intéressant
je n'en peux plus a dit elle c'est pas
un trop gros talent pour une petite
place c'est exactement ça il mérite
mieux camille mais bon si la donga
je crains qu'il n'ait raison à cyril
hélas le moi je crains tu ne lise un
prompteur justement